welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and this is a breakdown
of Warner Brothers latest Adventure
Wonka this movie did such a great job of
bringing Whimsy to my cold dead heart
it's a bundle of fun and surprisingly
yet unsurprisingly very Charming the
talent the writing choreography and
homages did I mention choreography yes
because it's a musical what feels pretty
spontaneous is actually very ordinary
for a man who dreams of being the
world's best choler so here I'll be
breaking down Wonka and exploring all
those Easter eggs and details you might
have missed and please support our
Channel further with our new for all
time always sh with Loki with the Elle
World tree at nerd rot. shop we love it
you're going to love it uh everybody's
going to love it okay let's get into it
the movie opens with the production
logos in a little acoustic lullab
rendition of Pure Imagination and that
song makes me want to ball my eyes out
but we'll save it to the end of the
movie additionally this is the first
time I've seen the r doll story company
production credit since Netflix acquired
them a couple years ago I think on the
Wonka bar the W in the middle is of
course for Willy Wonka that's Matilda to
the left below is a mouse I think that's
for the witches the top right is Mr Fox
and the potion to the top left is
probably George's Marvelous Medicine we
all tried taking a stab at that in new
rock stars you can also see a Giant
Peach from James the giant peach in the
bottom right corner Gina found that
because I can't see in that maze when we
meet our young Willy Wonka played by
Timothy shalamay he's got his iconic Top
Hat Kane and purple suit fun fact the
costume designer for this movie is Lindy
Heming who also did costume design for
The Dark Knight it's also not surprising
that he somewhat resembles the Joker
timy mentions in an interview with BBC
Radio 1 that since he's the young Wonka
who hasn't made it yet his outfit must
be battered and tattered and bruised
like the Jokers Wonka jumps off the ship
waving goodbye to his fellow Shipmates
and rides into town on Maru and Phill's
wine truck cuz we all know candy is
dandy but liquor is quicker see what I
did there I'm full of imagination this
scene where he spins on the pole is when
he notes in the same BBC Radio one
interview he pulled his shoulder and how
grueling and physically challenging it
was to do a musical but equally as
rewarding and when you see this movie
you see how rewarding it can be we then
see Wonka's competing chocolate
slugworth and fickle grber also how
funny is the the dance scene when we see
he's actually dancing alone it's just
hilarious this is also where we're
introduced to officer ad played by CNA
Brook Smith I love how old and juny
everything looks this movie is set 25
years before the events of wily Wonka in
the Chocolate Factory which was set in
the movie in 1971 so it's the late 1940s
the production design is led by Nathan
Crowley who also worked on The Dark
Knight and did production design for the
greatest showman Paul King the writer
and director said that that was a really
beautiful movie that was shot on a
really tight budget he really pulled it
all off and David Hammond was also one
of the producers he did Barbie and Harry
Potter so with that combined willpower
and Willy Wonka I assume there was a lot
of World building going on here when
Wonka's sad but still optimistically
walks down the stairs in the beginning
number he does the Gene Wilder iconic
walk down and walk back up the steps he
did during Pure
[Music]
Imagination he then flips the coin and
it lands in the sewer drain reminding us
how Charlie found the coin in the sewer
drain and that coin got him his winning
ticket later in the movie then he's
approached by bleacher played by Tom
Davis and this scene feels EX exactly
like slugworth coming up to Charlie in
the original movie like he's trying to
sink his teeth into this innocent boy
then we meet miss scrubb it played by
Olivia Coleman and gosh I love it this
character feels exactly like Miss love
it from Sweeny Todd they're both Shady
women always offering and drinking Jin
and they both have old timey orphans the
silliness of how long the contract is is
probably related to the original film's
long contract that no one could read
especially with that fine print being
too small to read just like in the
original film where the gates open at
10:00 a.m. the gates open to the gallery
Gourmet at the same time 10 am little
nods Wonka pulls out his mother's
homemade Wonka chocolate bar what kept
Him making chocolate dreaming about
chocolate and wanting to be a choler the
homemade packaging is made with the same
font we saw in the 71 movie fun fact and
Side Story when I was a little child I
went to Toys RS got a Wonka bar and it
had a Golden Ticket inside and I told my
mom and she she made me cry because she
wouldn't take me to the Chocolate
Factory and I lost the chance of meeting
Willy Wonka so just next time great
films like this want to make merch for
heavily Whimsical children think twice
about it because it was Soul crushing
when I found out it wasn't a real place
place then we hear Timothy's iconic line
from the trailer scratch that reverse it
we know that comes from the original
movie When Willy Wonka ushers all the
guest into the factory strike that
reverse it Wonka then plays his little
flute to fix his pitch later we see Hugh
Grant as the Oompa Loompa use it as a
call out to Jean Wilder playing that bad
boy after every child was in
danger Wonka sings his song you've never
had chocolate like this where he
describes finding these hover flies in
Mumbai and they lay chocolate like eggs
Wily Wonka always mentioned his days
traveling to find the Loompas and Loompa
land in the original movie and in the
2005 one he was always traveling to find
the next best flavor then we meet the
real competition we got prognos play by
Matt Lucas fickle grber played by
Matthew Bon and slugworth played by
Patterson Joseph they're wearing green
yellow and blue and I couldn't get that
out of my head it feels like they're
wearing the matching wardrobe to like
the Lollipop Guild from Wizard of Oz
they might be my favorite villains of
all time and they're having so much fun
in these roles I love them so much in
this movie then we know what this scene
reminds us all of the fizzy lifting
drinks they fill you with gas and the
gas gas is so terrifically lifting that
it lifts you right off the ground like a
balloon they even make a comment how
they're going to fart it out later a
different gas that the fizzy lifting
drinks gives
you a mysterious Vault teeming with
danger and wonder has opened are you
ready to embark on this secret journey
to explore the relics and ruins now
Magic the Gathering is letting you take
on the role of legendary Explorer L coft
with their new secret lair collaboration
this secret lirer drop is awesome it's
got fan favorite cards like Shadow Spear
and Academy ruins with Tomb Raider and
spired Art Plus an allnew mechanically
unique Laura Croft Tomb Raider card this
drop is available exclusively through
the secret lair website it's got six
cards total plus a treasure token and
even better the secret layer Tomb Raider
drop is available now just click the
link in the description below and get
yours today then we're introduced to the
chief of police played by Keegan Michael
Key who's in the pockets of the evil
chocolateers but his character is also
very fun and you can tell he's
improvising the entire time we're also
introduced to the rest of the team Jim
Carter as Abacus crunch the accountant
Natasha Rothwell as Piper Ben the
plumber rcky thakra as lahti Bell the
telephone operator and rich fure as
Larry Chuckles worth the comedian who I
think is actually a comedian or just
does a million comedic roles he should
be familiar to you so if you sign the
contract without reading the fine print
you have a debt to missg Grubb it and
you must pay that debt by cleaning all
of her laundry Abus says you're on Suds
and that should immediately remind you
of this scene swifter than
Eagles stronger than
Lions but the entire wash and clothes
scene should remind you that Charlie and
his mom have a heart-to-heart washing
clothes the same way then later making
it into a working rub Goldberg machine
should remind you of the Everlasting Gob
stopper machine he even uses winter
coats because the concoction is too cold
or a shoe when it needs a kick then we
hear Sweet Tooth which is literally my
favorite song on the sound trck I love
this song when Wonka Runs Out of Milk to
make chocolate noodle offers a bottle
sitting on someone's doorstep which
Wonka is heavily against cuz it's
stealing and we all know how he feels
about thieves you stole fizzy lifting
drinks also Wonka says a that's stealing
and C Wily Wonka doesn't use cow's milk
showing he's still just very illiterate
then we meet the security guard of the
zoo play by Simon farnaby love him and
ghost he's also the co-writer for this
movie The Big KN out chocolate is like
the three course meal and a stick of
chewing gum that Violet borgard consumes
in the 71 film Wonka has this weird
connection to flamingos throughout the
entire movie at the zoo they mentioned
how flamingos don't fly because they
need someone to show them which could be
a metaphor for how Wonka needs
assistance and his eyes are opened by
his friends Paul King mentioned in a
letterbox interview Willie arrives and
believes if you tell him to work hard
everything will fall into place but of
course it's not always that
straightforward he wanted to show and
relate to everyone in this way Wonka can
it's not always going to work out and
that's okay sometimes you need a secure
support system to get you through it all
another song that I really love is Willi
and noodles Zeus song it's so precious
I'm obsessed with the sequence too not
only because it reminds me of the Cheer
Up Charlie song from the original movie
and how his mom is trying to cheer him
up this also resembles the ending of the
original Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory movie when the rocket elevator
comes out of the ceiling I might be
reading too much into this scene but in
this scene where the chief officer is
dunking Wonka's head into the fountain
he says you understand me Wonka yells
back there's water in my ears which
reminds me of this scene of someone
yelling at Wonka and him just outright
ignoring that child we also see Wonka
has been handing out these lifetime
supplies of chocolate vouchers he said
he'd give noodle her share going forward
then we meet our Hugh Grant Oompa Loompa
and this oompaloompa is very
sophisticated he then starts doing the
oompaloompa song and danc and it's
pretty cute watching hug Grant do all of
this then he gets the best line he
eggsit saying good day I said good day
sir it's probably everyone's favorite
line from the original movie the most
iconic one in his upgraded Willy Wonka
hat and coat he walks the red carpet
like he did in the original movie
guiding his followers inside they tried
to do the Gene Wilder roll in the roll
itself is nearly impossible timoy said
with BBC Radio one he assumed in the
original they built a hole in the ground
for Gan Wilder but they couldn't make
that scene happen the little Wonka candy
shop feels like a mini version of what
the factory looks like in the original
movie edible flowers grass cups and
buckets it's the same Whimsy even when a
child is picked up and lifted to some
treats like Vero was in the movie they
eat clouds here and I just love this I
love this too much and the song is so
sweet Paul King how dare you in Noodle's
flashback story she's tossed down a
laundry shoot as a baby to be orphan
which feels Loosely like Vero assault
being launched down the trash shoot that
leads to the furnace when Noodle and won
are left to drown in chocolate it makes
you wonder if this is the prequel to
willly Wonka Jee Wilder shouldn't Jee
Wilder have been like really caring
about Augustus Gloop scene as he's been
in the exact same situation I just it's
kind of crazy that he does not care what
happens to Augustus and the next film we
learn the secret to the best chocolate
is who you share it with and in a real
mean girl's moment Wonka ktie Harin this
thing and splits up the chocolate
amongst his best friends it's the best
chocolate he's ever had and Q my tears
starting to rise up I can't do this then
he says he wishes it could last forever
I'll call out to his next biggest
invention the Everlasting Gob stopper
and that's meant to last forever and be
very affordable for everybody then yes
this is when I started crying in the
movie the entire Yang helped noodle find
her mom noodle would J dream of her her
mom living in a house full of books
waiting at her at the front door to give
her a big hug and exactly that scene
happens her house full of books is the
local library where she also lives oh
God I said God no and I started crying I
started crying in the theater and I was
seeing this by myself I was seeing this
by myself throughout the movie scrubb
calls noodle a bookworm or says she
lives in her books and we know why cuz
she's just like her mom and she likes
reading oh God she's me she's me for
real then we get Timothy's acoustic
version of Pure Imagination which made
it worse I was like stop this I was
crying like crazy then the Oompa Loompa
says another famous Jee Wilder quote so
shine's a good deed in a weary world you
grant got the best lines the pre Wonka
Factory is beginning he builds or I mean
this could also be him imagining but I
think he's building but he's got the
chocolate River and yellow teacups from
the original movie and that's it for my
breakdown on Wonka I really love this
movie it's perfectly silly it's very
Whimsical and it gives you the same
feeling Paddington did it worked very
well and I watched it twice and would
see it again the songs are catchy and it
it just all works follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at Lulu Clemens follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching I said good
[Music]
day